[Music]  the Royals renewed for another season  yes we're very excited about that we  just heard today we're coming back to  season four so we're very excited you  know it's such a sexy show I mean what  do you think it is but what makes a  person sexy I guess that point of view  well you know you're the envy of a lot  of the women in our office we'll have to  ask you what's the secret to Spain so in  shade and so gorgeous well nobody finds  any secret really is that we all know  it's some not going to bed too late not  really too much alcohol eating lots of  vegetables almost feels amazing and I  love right before the Globes you wish  Hugh Grant good luck and said he's been  your best friend for 29 years I mean  what's the secret to your last year  relationship because I've really been  there for each other despite being exes  you